i can feel you pulling things around in
there
it's a brand new organ
never before seen
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
and we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could fill it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more
dangerous place now that pain has all
but disappeared
[Music]
surgery is sex isn't it
is it
you know it is
surgery is the new sex
[Music]
i don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
which is why i keep cutting it up
what do you think they'd find inside
outer space
sorry
let us not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create a map
that will guide us
into the heart of darkness
[Music]
you